[Music]
how can i escape doom scrolling and
reduce the distraction of social media
throw your phone away throw your laptop
away so this this phenomenon recently
coined doom scrolling
it's almost as though
we are seeking out
our own doom our own discontent in ways
and the reason we do that is because we
do get something from it otherwise we
wouldn't do it evolutionarily it
wouldn't make sense just like the reason
our attention pings from one place to
another is to so we don't get eaten by
some predator or attacked by some other
tribe and so that's a feature
but also the doom scrolling we're
getting something out of us or at least
we're telling ourselves that we're
getting something out of seeking out
that news or that information i would
not i would not uh put that second point
on as a given
uh you know just accept that people are
doing this like that not that we are we
are supposed to or that there's some
value that we're getting out of it i
would put that as a question mark are we
getting some value out of this because
there's a very important component that
we have to acknowledge
we are not neutral participants in a
fair fight with social media
social media has been designed by not
just an engineer or two but teams of
algorithm builders that have designed
ways to harness our attention not just
broadly speaking like stuff that's
that's fear inducing or that's
interesting or that's um novel will get
us it's for us it's customized to our
particular interests our particular
fearful qualities our particular um
exciting things that we like so the the
chances of us being able to fight the
lure that is designed for us to want to
invest our attention in it look there's
no chance
there's no chance so we have to remember
that that the so that's why i question
mark the that we're doing this for some
reason i think that we have to remember
that
and there's other people that have
started talking about this notion of an
attention economy that we are
participants you know if you're not
paying for the product you are the
product is another shorthand for this
yes so to remember that to remember that
this is the situation i met now a lot of
the advice given regarding what to do
about breaking up with your phone etc
you know i'm not convinced that that's
necessarily all that helpful
because um
it's almost like food at this point like
you've got to figure out a different
relationship if it's a problematic one
so what is the way i'm gonna have a
different relationship now
the first thing we can do to arm
ourselves against this very unfair fight
is to acknowledge it's an unfair fight
like you know i'm not gonna win this
so how can i
behave in a way that's strategic and
advantages me without fighting like how
can i set myself up so that i don't have
to fight yes so so this is where it's
not going to be the most uh quick fix
answer but it's the one that's probably
going to help us the most it's to use
those same
qualities of attention that we're
cultivating
focus notice redirect
so for example
we and and really mindfulness in this
context of moment-to-moment awareness of
what is happening in our moment i mean
in our in our experience so um the next
time you are here's what i think
probably happens and it happens to me
too i mean we're all a work in progress
typically you're 30 minutes into your
tick-tock
time before somebody taps you on the and
says hey you said you were going to do
blah or you're like oh crap i forgot to
pick up my kid from school whatever it
is some external thing
gets you to wake up out of the
lure
of this completely consuming engagement
with pick your app of choice i don't
care
so
how did that happen i mean nobody put
you there with your eyes on the phone no
you did that yourself at some point you
picked up the phone you actually looked
at the phone you put your code in or you
did face activation you clicked on an
app you read and scrolled through the
app your finger moved multiple times
that was not happening by a robot that
was happening by you yourself but i'm
positive most of us have no memory of
any of that and have no awareness that
we did all of those steps yes so if we
think about our phone itself as an
opportunity to practice mindfulness we
can take a different approach
you know just notice the experience of
holding the phone
literally i'm in this moment i feel the
phone notice the act remember that
you're doing this of getting into the
app
notice that you're actually clicking and
what i recommend people to do to really
help themselves is have a goal for why
you're going to engage with this
particular app and and once you achieve
that goal
acknowledge that you've achieved that
goal and ask yourself do i need to
continue so you know like for me and i
describe this i wanted to buy like new
uh a new pan and then i'm like all of a
sudden i'm like listening to 50
different food bloggers talk about you
know how to prepare tofu in a certain
way with an air fryer it's like what am
i doing
but
what you can do is say the purpose of
this engagement is to find a new pan and
find some trusted sources on it have i
done that yes do i want to keep going
should i keep going those are all choice
points and then you can decide in that
moment but if you are completely
oblivious there's no chance
so that's just some of the some of the
helpful ways we can really use our
phones as a way to practice mindfulness
actually yeah yeah i mean it's
it would be easy to just sit here and i
guess it might be easier you know to
fast than it is to diet but to throw
away your phone to get rid of your
screens there's gonna be some
some inconvenience there's gonna be some
pain that you're gonna have to deal with
so
finding a way to do do it mindfully and
noticing each step of it um yeah i mean
that'll at least help us to have a
better control of that flashlight rather
than yeah the doom scrolling for sure i
i stopped looking at the news like two
months ago i stopped
um like back at the beginning of last
year and then it started back up again
um and i just realized like that's
exactly what i was doing i was
doom-scrolling i was i was looking for
something to arouse you know
my my curiosity or my fears or whatever
it was
and just by not looking at the news and
being more deliberate about that i find
myself
being at peace more i i'm worrying much
less and never did i didn't look at the
news one time last year and thought oh
thank god i found out about that
thank god i was informed about that
like if there's you know if there's a
major catastrophe for us like i'm going
to hear about it i don't i don't really
have to look at the news to find out
about true emergencies typically as
amishi highlighted
these
corporations multinational
trillion-dollar corporations
make money by aggregating your eyeballs
onto their products and services they're
trying to sell to you so you are also
becoming the product and so the reason
that facebook is quote unquote free or
instagram is free or tick-tock is free
because
it's free monetarily but there is no
refund for misspen attention
right and so we're spending we're
wasting we're squandering our attention
and so we do get something out of it
now
these demographers statisticians
algorithm scientists
are
feeding us what david foster wallace
referred to as food pellets from the
universe but they're like empty calories
in a way so we feel as though we're
getting something
because it tastes sweet
metaphorically
but it doesn't nourish us the same way
that if our attention was focused on the
thing we wanted to be focused on were
essentially as ryan said we're going out
and distracting ourselves or in your
case you were seeking out something to
be upset about in a way was seeking out
an emotional response yeah and i think
that's i would say that i don't know if
it's all food pellets and empty calories
i would say i'm more
i'm more agnostic about that because i
think there's some really beautiful
stuff that we yeah i learned about
youtube from stuff on social media so
like i would say that i don't want to
make it an all or none
issue i think that the key to maneuver
through is to demand
more responsible um
action from these giant companies for
example don't allow the scroll allow uh
essentially a page break as simple as
that because we know you've read
articles right where it's like do you
want to advance to the next screen to
keep reading and that's a decision point
it's like oh i don't have time right now
the scroll makes it continuous which and
extends the chances that you are going
to
make a decision regarding continuing
yeah so simple things that can be done i
think that that needs to happen but the
other point is
we need to
change our relationship and realize that
we have a we we will need to change our
relationship
and what you were saying regarding you
know the um maybe even searching out
things to get angry or upset about
um
to
really notice that to really notice that
because in the same way that we talk
about you know again food there's a lot
of parallels there it's like oh i'm
doing this because of this
you know it that's fine and that is it's
a it's it's sort of this thing in
psychology where there's this whole
notion of change the thoughts change the
content of the thoughts
what i'm saying is you can do that
that's fine there's cognitive behavioral
therapy there's other approaches and
that's very useful but the other way is
change the way that you are paying
attention in your engagement with
whatever you're doing yes and you can't
do that unless you start cultivating the
capacity to know where your attention is
it goes back to what i was saying
earlier pay attention to your attention
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free